we need to discuss something it's uh it
is well known if you're a regular
listener to the podcast that uh
sona is
i don't want to say an amoral person
come on uh uh but uh sona has committed
many crimes uh you've confessed on the
tv show to your thefts in the past
you're sorted past uh stealing things in
stores and um before uh covet hit we
actually wanted to shoot a remote where
we brought you back to all the different
stores where you've stolen things how'd
you admit to stealing them and then uh
return those goods or pay the cash
equivalent and we were going to do that
but then i think this is the biggest
tragedy of kovid
we weren't able to shoot that remote
that and of course
all the loss of life and stuff um
economy but but yeah one of the biggest
tragedies of covid was that we didn't
get to shoot that remote uh but
we were just chatting and sona started
to reveal
another of her heinous crimes okay and i
felt we needed to um record this
because i don't even understand yeah
explain this again explain this it's not
explain this grift uh you started to
talk about in back in the day when you
would go to an all-you-can-eat sushi
place continue sona okay so
the first of all it's not a heinous
crime it's i think let's call it
despicable despicable thank you yeah why
don't we let the jury decide the jury
being our listeners okay of course me
being the judge so i can overrule the
jury in this weird kangaroo court go
ahead sona tell us about this scam so if
you go to some all you can eat sushi
restaurants some people over order and
then they end up with a lot of extra
sushi so because a lot of people would
over order these sushi restaurants will
charge you for whatever sushi you don't
eat right yeah yes they should because
it's not like they can give that sushi
to someone else right and you know it's
sushi it's not like you're going to a
buffet and like you know you're like
piling up your plate you're ordering
sushi that people are making anyway so
this sounds like a very sane and
rational policy okay so my my friends
and i we would go to these all you can
eat sushi restaurants and you know we
have a little bit to drink you know like
you know
i wished
yeah you would have a lot to drink or
have a massive cerebral event
a brain bleed yeah the sake is flowing
the sapporo's flowing and then you just
order too much and what i would do is i
would when the waiters weren't looking i
would shove all of the extra sushi which
was a lot into
one of the dinner napkins and then i
would like hide it in my shirt or shove
it in my purse and then i'd go to the
bathroom and i'd throw it away
what you wouldn't even you wouldn't even
you wouldn't take it home and eat it
that's that's you threw it away
why would i want more sushi and why
wouldn't maybe you give it to somebody
somebody who could eat it what kind of
creep takes out sushi from their purse
wrapped in you apparently no but i mean
first of all just imagine for a second
imagine that you are a tuna
and you're swimming in the sea and
suddenly you're snared in a net and
hauled up my great purpose i'm going to
be some sushi you think for a second
well my life has been short
but it i see that they're taking me to a
sushi restaurant
and before i completely
lose consciousness
at least myself i will create happiness
my
flesh
will go to sustain another species
in this great mystery
and cycle of life
at least that gives me some joy wait
what they're chopping me now okay i'm
still somewhat alive somehow and they're
putting me with some rice hi i'm bilbo
the rare octopus they're bringing me
over to these
ladies oh well at least i'm just kind of
i can't believe i'm still kind of alive
but i am i'm able to see at least
going to go into the mouths of
what shoved in a napkin my entire
corporeal form
my body she's taking me maybe outside to
give to someone who has no food
wait not the lady's room
shoved
shoved in a trash can
jesus mary and joseph
i'm a catholic
tuna fish
ladies and gentlemen of the jury we rest
our case
that's awful that's the worst sona
that's the worst thing i've heard stop
that is worse than that guy that was
trying to like people that are faking
vaccine cards or making fake covid
serums that don't even work
you're the worst criminal than them you
threw fresh
sushi
into
a ladies room trash can how recent ago
was this
ago
you know what it was i was working for
conan so it was within what
i thought this was something you did
when you were
sixteen or seventeen from watching your
dad seriously no i thought this was a
long time ago because twenties maybe
working for me late twenties late
twenties early thirties late late 20s i
don't criminal war criminal it's not cr
why are you making the restaurant all
you can eat sushi and then charging me
for the extras just say it's a normal
sushi restaurant what's the point sure
you do have a point there thank you
thank you no no you have no point
leave it there pay the price
those octopi
gave their lives and we all know those
are very intelligent creatures they've
written books they uh there's that
octopus the man this they have the
brains of like uh i think they've done
studies octopi have the brains of like a
25 year old graduate what
yeah someone who went to brown
university that's how smart they are
you know that's how smart and and they
gave their lives and you're like
i don't want to pay for this there's a
documentary called my octopus teacher so
that means that octopuses are like
certified tenured teachers
also did you see did you stay and watch
the credits you know who directed the
movie the octopus that's right oh god
and you know who got the funding for it
other octopi
that's how smart they are well and
that's how smart they'd be
um sorry but if we're talking about sea
creatures i had to go a little bit into
a pirate uh sona yeah you are
undoubtedly the worst person i've ever
met what the hell
yeah i'm getting now where i'm looking i
have a device here that allows me to see
the listeners and yes overwhelmingly
it's coming in
people think that you're a monster yeah
we're going to have to remand you into
custody right now straight from the
courtroom yeah you're being sensed you
know what we're going to do now we're
going to go back to that all you can eat
sushi place and you have to
are going to bring the
live fish to those restaurants what how
they're going to bring live fish to
those restaurants
and you're going to show them what you
did they'll be kept alive in oxygenated
tanks huh and uh they will and you will
confess to the crimes at that restaurant
okay and then we'll leave the fish there
at the restaurant so they can be
butchered and thrown out by someone else
i didn't give this punishment you're
really bad at punishments i was about to
say that so you want me wait you want me
to bring fresh fish to a sushi
restaurant and then make them make me
sushi and then i'm not great at
punishment okay
uh but sona if you disagree with me i'll
put you
in a jail cell made of white chocolate
and you'll be forced
to watch
different spoons
seasons one and three that's your
punishment different spoons i don't even
know what that is
oh you're on trial
you're gonna watch it you're on track
you're gonna watch silver strokes and
different spoons
silver strokes is what you're having
right now yeah you messed up i love it
when you mess up this is my favorite
you're trying to make me look bad no on
per you know what i did huh i switched
it around on purpose to give everyone
out there in their morning commute also
i don't want to do this because i hate
hate when people do this but it's not
octopi it's octopuses it's greek i was
referring to octopuses that have been
ground up and put into a pie which is
referred to as an octopi
so
that's what i was referring to i don't
know what you were talking about but i'm
correct when octopuses
are chopped up and minced and put in a
pie it's an octopi
your honor i rest my case sona guilty
girly guilty oh here's the verdict for
conan oh innocent and gets a nine
hundred dollar credit
and any bob's big boy
of course
nope uh trust me i am judge jury and
sexecutioner
what a way to die
[Music]
[Laughter]